ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES ATKINS
JEFF BRADFORD BY ADAM FOR
TESTING DALLY GOD TORONTO EDMUND
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HERZBERG
WESSEL HER TADO JONES CAM WALKER
LAYERED LEYVA THE MON WHY ARE
MELINDA'S MIN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
SHOW OF BOTH PAM BORTON TINA
BROUGHT RUBIO SKINNER STERN
AMBERG BY CAL SKI. WINNER WELL.
CORMAN'S PRESENTS WITH MEMBERS
OR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE BUT WE WERE LED IN
PRAYER BY SENATOR ALSO
AFTERWARDS PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. BY
SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. BUT MERCY AND WISDOM
WE BRING BEFORE YOU ALL THE
WOMEN WHOSE STORIES WE HAVE
WITNESSED AND WHOSE STORIES HAVE
SHAPED OUR LIVES OUR MOTHERS
GUARDIANS AND FRIENDS. FILL US
WITH YOUR COMPASSION THAT WE MAY
WORK TIRELESSLY. TO ALLEVIATE
THE SUFFERING OF ALL WOMEN.
THOSE WHOSE VOICES HAVE BEEN
LEFT UNHEARD. THOSE WHO AGAINST
ALL ODDS CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT
OF LOVE AND PEACE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. THOSE WHOSE STORIES
ARE DIFFERENT FROM OUR OWN. FILL
US WITH YOUR COURAGE THAT WE MAY
BRING HOPE TO THOSE WHO LIVE IN
FEAR THAT OUR ACTIONS MAY BE
ROOTED IN INCLUSIVITY JUSTICE
AND LOVE. THAT WE MAY CONTRIBUTE
TO THE HEALING AND WHOLENESS OF
OUR WORLD A MAN. A MAN. PLEASE
JOIN ME AS WE SALUTE OUR FLAG. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
MADAM PRESIDENT I AM DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED ON ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SENATE
BILL ONE NINETEEN AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
HONORABLE BODY TO CONCURRENCE
THAT AMENDMENTS TO PARKER CHIEF
CLERK OFTHE ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILL
ORDER TWENTY MINUTES BUSINESS
FILE. THANK YOU BUT REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED.
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOVING
ON NOW IS THE TIME FOR MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. BUT
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF MARCH
SEVENTH TO THE TEN. TO THE-
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE COURT.
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATIONS OF
THE DAILY FILE WE'LL START WITH
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. FIVE
AND ONE SATURDAY'S. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF ON A LOST SOUL AS DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES PRIOR TO THIS ROLE IN
THIS LOST SOUL WAS EXPOSITION
PARK GENERAL MANAGER AT THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY SHE WAS APPROVED IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY THIRD ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. NINE MINUTES OKAY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
FIVE ADKINS I HATE. HI BECKER I
PORCHES BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW
I PROTESTING. I DALLY. DOT HI
TORONTO HI A COMMON. FIVE BLAZER
I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HI HURTS
BY WEST SO. I FURTADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR.
MON I REQUIRE. REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH HI
PAM. I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI STERN.
FIVE AMBERG HI I WAS KIND OF
SCARY. I WINNER HI WELL I. THE
EYES ARE THIRTY SEVEN THE-
PLEASE CALL THE EIGHT MINUTE
SECULAR PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. PORCHES DALLY I LEAVE A. THE EYES ARE THIRTY EIGHT THE
NOTES ARE ZERO THE POINT IS
CONFIRMED. WELCOME TO SATURDAY'S
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF WILLIAM LOU TO THE GAMBLING
CONTROL COMMISSION MR LIU HAS
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE AS AN
AUDITOR AND ACCOUNTANT AND
PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON THE
GAMBLING GAMING POLICY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OF THE GAMBLING
CONTROL COMMISSION HE WAS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE
ZERO VOTE IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MARCH NINTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. NINE
MINUTES AFTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
I FACE I BECKER. I PORCHES
BRADFORD I HAVE A HERO HI
PROTESTING HI DOLLY I TODD FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN I PLEASER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH HIGH
SPURRED HI WEST SO. ALL RIGHT-
TANTO I JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LABOR MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM
I PERSON TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL I.
HIGHS ARE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE POINT IS CONFIRMED. FILE
ITEM THREE GENERATES THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
COAL MORGAN THREE APPOINTMENTS
TO THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD MISS MORGAN SERVES
ON THE BOARDS POSITION FOR A
CIVIL ENGINEER WITH EXPERIENCE
IN THE FIELDS OF WATER SUPPLY
AND WATER RIGHT PRIOR TO THIS
ROLE SHE SERVED AS STATE BOARD
STAFF IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MARCH NINTH ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOAT. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR. AT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I HAD CAN
I FACE I BECKER BYE BYE FORTUS
RADFORD I HAVE A DAUGHTER I FOR
TESTING HI DOLLY. DOT HI TORONTO
I EGGMAN I BELIEVE HER. ONE
DOLLAR I GROW HI HEARD SPURRED
BY WESTERN. I HER DAUGHTER NO
JONES. I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED.
LABOUR. THE MON I WIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM
I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS I RUBIO
I SKINNER HI STERN HI AMBER HI
WHAT COUNTS SKI FIVE WINNER I
WILL HI. THIRTY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST DALLY.
LAYERED I EVA MELINDA'S. THE
EYES ARE THIRTY FIVE THE NOTES
ARE ONE THE POINT IS CONFIRMED.
THE FIVE MOVING ONTO FILE NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER FOUR FENNER BASE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DEBORAH BARNES JUNE KIM LOPEZ
DAVID RABBIT CINDY SILVA AND
VINCENT WELLS TO THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION ALL FIVE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED ON THE
IMAC UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
NINTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ADKINS I FACE HI BACKER. FIVE I
FORTUS BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM
HYPERTENSIVE I DOLLY. DOT I
TORONTO HI A GUNMAN I BELIEVE
HER. I CONSOLIDATE I GROW BY
HERTZ BERG. I WAS SO I HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I FLAVOR THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S HI MAN I. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN
I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I RUBIO
HI SKINNER HI STERN HI I'M BERG
HI FORECASTING I WINNER I WILL.
HI. THIRTY PLEASE CALL THE APRS
MEMBERS. FORTUS TALLY I LLEVA.
THE EYES ARE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ARE ZERO DEPLOYMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW MEMBERS ARE TURNING TO
ASSEMBLY MESSAGES SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE.
MADAM PRESIDENT I AM DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTEEN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOUR HONORABLE BODY
CONCURS INSIDE AMENDMENTS TO
PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILL ORDERED TWO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE.
MEMBERS THE NEXT ITEM ON OUR
AGENDA IS UNFINISHED BUSINESS IT
IS THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE WHICH
IS NOT. FINISHED AT THIS TIME SO
IN THE PAST THAT WILL RETURN TO
IT. IN DUE TIME. MEMBERS. PLEASE
TAKE ANY OF YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR IT'S VERY HARD TO
HEAR APPEAR WITHOUT ALL THE
CHATTER MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND TAKE UP THE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY IF YOU COULD
PLEASE SIT AND LISTEN CAREFULLY
SENATOR BECKER. THE SENATE WE'RE
ALL MEMBERS AND- SENATOR BAKER
WERE MOVING ON TO- MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND THESE ARE THE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
COKE'S I RIGHT TO JOIN A MEMORY
OF KATIE MEYER. KATIE WAS THE
CHAMPION GOALKEEPER FIRST EVER
WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM. SHE HAVE
THE CARNABY NORTH CAROLINA TWO
IN STANFORD'S THIRD NCAA WOMEN'S
SOCCER TITLE. WITH TWO MEMORABLE
PENALTY SHOT SAVE TO WIN THE
GAME. SHE PLAYED FOR THREE
SEASONS FOR A TOTAL OF FIFTY
GAMES WINNING THIRTY FOUR OF
THOSE MATCHES. THIS PAST FALL
SHE STARTED NINETEEN OF THE
TWENTY GAMES MAKING FORTY FIVE
SAVES. AND SHE WAS TWICE NAMED
THE PAC TWELVE. ACADEMIC HONOR
ROLL. GOING UP IN NEWBURY PARK
IN VENTURA COUNTY SHE'S ON THE
NEWBURY PARK FOOTBALL TEAM FOR
TWO SEASONS. AS A KICKER. HER
FRIEND JUST GRAB HER AS LARGER
THAN LIFE TEAM PLAYER. BOTH ON.
AND OFF THE FIELD. NOT ONLY WAS
SHE OUTSTANDING STUDENT ATHLETE
. BUT ALSO A LEADER IN THE
UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY. CHOOSE AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE WOMEN'S SOCCER
PROGRAM AND FOR WOMEN'S SPORTS
IN GENERAL. MEYER PASSED AWAY ON
MARCH FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO. HER
SPIRIT LIVES ON HER FAMILY HER
TEAMMATES AND THE FOUNDATION
FRIENDS HOPE TO START IN HER
NAME TO RAISE AWARENESS OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN MEMORY
OF KATIE MEYER. PLEASE BRING HER
NAME TO THE DEATHS OF THAT SHE
MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR EDMUND. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- TODAY I RISE
AND ASKED THE SENATE ADJOURNED
AND THE MEMBERS OF DEAN DO YOU
KNOW OUR RECORD A POSSE DINO WAS
BORN SEPTEMBER TWENTY SECOND
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND DIED
RATHER SUDDENLY COMPLICATIONS OF
A STROKE ON FEBRUARY TENTH TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWO.
CANACCORD APOLOGY OF STOCKTON
PASSED AWAY- HE WAS THE SON OF
ITALIAN IMMIGRANTS HIS PARENTS
WERE AMERIGO INTERESA COURT
APOLOGY FROM STOCKTON. AFTER
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
ISN'T JUST A FARM FARM BOY HE
LIKED TO CALL HIMSELF. IN
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE HE WAS IN
THE VOCATIONAL TRACK AND HE
DEVELOPED A RHEUMATIC FEVER- AND
THEN HIS HEART BECAME WEAK AND
THEY SAID YOU CAN'T WORK RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE YOUR HEART IS TOO
WEAK. OF COURSE HE WOULDN'T STOP
AND THEN HE ENDED UP HAVING A
HEART ATTACK- AND HIS SOON TO BE
FATHER IN LAW THE CARLY WHO
BECAME LATER MAYOR STOCKTON SAID
YOU SHOULD GO TO. THE LEFT TO
FARM YOU SHOULD GO TO DAVIS AT
THE BEST SCHOOL IN THE COUNTRY
TO PERFORMING. OTHERS WOULD
DISAGREE AT THIS POINT THOSE
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HE
GRADUATED WITH A ASSOCIATES
DEGREE- AND THEN WENT ON TO
WORK- FOR PILLSBURY AS A GRAIN
BUYER HE CALLED OUT HIS MBA.
FROM PILLSBURY- HE MARRIED HIS
HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART JOAN TO
CARLY AT MORRIS CHAPEL IN
STOCKTON AND THEY HAD FOUR
CHILDREN GINO KATIE BECKY AND
DAVID. FROM NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
TO TWO THOUSAND AND TWO DO YOU
KNOW WAS INVOLVED IN FARMING AND
AGRIBUSINESS HIS FATHER THINK
INFORMING WAS TOO HARD TO LIFE
DID NOT LEAVE THE FARM TO DO YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY WERE. DOING
FIFTEEN ACRES BUT HE WAS
DETERMINED AND BY THE TIME HE
DIED HE WAS FARMING OUR
CONTROLLING OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
ACRES. IN CALIFORNIA OF
AGRIBUSINESS EVERYONE DESCRIBES
HIM AS LARGER. THAN LIFE IN A
FORCE OF NATURE- HIGH INTENSE
PERSON- HE HAD MULTIPLE.
PARTNERS INCLUDING COURT PARTY
PARTNERS COCOA FARMS DEL REAL
PARTNERS LOAN I FARMING- ALL OF
THESE STILL OWNED AND OPERATED
OFTENTIMES BY DINO- AND THEN HE
BECAME INTERESTED IN THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE COUCH. AS YOU LIKE
TO CALL IT A PROCESSING PACKING
MARKETING SIDE OF AGRIBUSINESS.
ARE HE AND- HAD STANDS UP FOR
PRODUCTS GARY CANNING SIERRA
QUALITY CANNERS AMIR GLAND
TOMATOES IN COURT TO OLIVE OIL.
HE PROBABLY ALL USE THE PRODUCTS
THAT HE DEVELOPED. HE UNDERSTOOD
ALL OF THESE AND HAD A REAL
FINESSE IN THINGS HE LOVED BEING
PRESENTED WITH A PROBLEM.
DEVELOPING A COUPLE AS- POSSIBLE
OPTIONS AND THEN LETTING PEOPLE
PICK THE REST HE LOVED THE
CHALLENGED WELL CALCULATED
RISKS- HE ALSO LOVE THINGS LIKE
FLY FISHING DUCK HUNTING- HE-
PEOPLE MAY REMEMBER. HE SUED IN
NINETEEN. M. EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY
NINETY SUED LIBBY MCNEIL AND
LIBBY FOR BREACH OF CONTRACT ONE
THAT. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HE
SUED THEN GOVERNOR ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER FOR MISMANAGEMENT
OF CALIFORNIA STATE FUNDS. AND
YOU MAY REMEMBER IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN HE STARTED STATEWIDE.
CAMPAIGN AGAINST JERRY BROWN'S-
THE HE TRIED TO DO THE PROP
FIFTY THREE CRUSADE AGAINST
REVENUE BONDS AND HE HAD.
ARTICLES AND ALL PAPERS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE LIAR LIAR PANTS
ON FIRE. HE NEVER BACKED AWAY
FROM A FIGHT I THINK WHEN HE
DIED HE WAS STILL SUING- THE AT
IT. ONE OF THE FOUNDATIONS
WORKING TOWARDS RESTORING THE
DELTA- HE DESIGNED HIS OWN ARM
HE DESIGNED AT MOST EVERYTHING
AROUND HIM- HIS WITH HIS
FAVORITE SAYINGS WHERE LIFE IS A
BANQUET AT WHICH MANY GO HUNGRY.
ARITHMETIC IS NOT AN OPINION.
CHANCE FAVORS THE PREPARED MIND.
AND GET IN POSITION AND GET
LUCKY. IT WAS MY HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO KNOW DINO COURT
APOLOGY HIS. EXTREME WORK ETHIC
HIS BELIEF IN THE GROUND IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT YOU PUT IN WHAT
YOU SOW IS WHAT YOU GETBACK.
HE'S INCREDIBLY STRATEGIC MIND
MOST A LOT OF THINGS IN STOCKTON
AND. INNOCENT LOOKING COUNTY
HAVE THE COURT OPPOSING NAME ON
IT THANK. J. FAMILY- AND WE
STAND AND ASK THE SENATE AND- IN
HIS- AND WISH OUR BEST TO HIS
FOUR CHILDREN HIS GRANDCHILDREN
AND HIS DEVOTED WIFE JOHN.
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO
THE DESK SO THAT HE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. HE WE'RE GONNA TAKE
OVER A TEN MINUTE RECESS SO THAT
WE CAN WAIT FOR THE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE TO ARRIVE HERE IN THE
SENATE. MAKE SURE TO PLEASE STAY
ON THE ON THE FLOOR.
ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU COULD TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR IF
YOU MUST HAVE THEM OTHERWISE
YOU'RE MOVING ON TO. UNFINISHED
BUSINESS THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
AND SENATOR SKINNER ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE.
YEAH YOUR RIGHT. TAKE IT. WHAT'S
MORE CENTERS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
EIGHTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MADAM PRESIDENT AND-
MEMBERS. YES P. ONE EIGHTEEN
ADDRESSES THE CIRCUMSTANCE WE
FIND OURSELVES NOW WE'RE WITHOUT
IMMEDIATE INTERVENTION UC
BERKELEY COULD BE FORCED OR
WOULD BE FORCED TO ENROLL FEWER
STUDENTS IN THIS UPCOMING FALL
BECAUSE OF A COURT ORDER TO. ONE
STUDENT ENROLLMENT THAT OCCURRED
IN THE CONTEXT OF A SEQUEL
LAWSUIT. THE COURT'S ORDER
CAPPING ENROLLMENT AT THE SAME
THE COURT'S ORDER CAPS
ENROLLMENT AT THE SAME LEVEL AS
FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BY DOING
THAT IT IMPACTS A LARGER NUMBER
OF STUDENTS THEN HAD THAT
CAPTAIN COULD STAY IN. TWO
PREVIOUS YEARS BECAUSE DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. UC BERKELEY'S FALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN ROMANS WAS
LOWER THAN THE PREVIOUS TWO
YEARS. TIME IS RUNNING OUT UC
BERKELEY'S REMAINING OFFERS OF
ADMISSION ARE SCHEDULED TO BE
ISSUED ON MARCH FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WITHOUT A SOLUTION
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
AND POTENTIALLY HIGHER STUDENTS
MAY LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND UC BERKELEY THIS FALL.
AND THAT HAS IMPLICATIONS ON ALL
OF OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
. AND I WILL DISCUSS WHILE I'M
DISCUSSING THE CIRCUMSTANCE OF
UC BERKELEY AT THE MOMENT WHAT
WE ARE ALSO ADDRESSING BY OUR
ACTION TODAY IS THE IMPLICATIONS
ON OUR THREE OTHER. OR NOT THREE
OTHER OR TO OTHER HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS PLUS ALL
OTHER UC CAMPUSES. NOW PUTTING A
CAP ON STUDENT ENROLLMENT IS
ALSO UNPRECEDENTED WHILE THE
STATUTE RELATING TO CAMPUS LONG
RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLANS HAS BEEN
IN EFFECT FOR THIRTY ODD YEARS
YEAH THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
LAWSUITS RELATED TO LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS AND THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS. THERE HAS
NEVER BEEN ISSUED A CAP ON
STUDENT ENROLLMENT. THE BILL
BEFORE US IS DESIGNED NOT ONLY
TO ELIMINATE THE DRASTIC IMPACT
ON UC BERKELEY'S ENROLLMENT FOR
THIS COMING FALL. BUT AS I
MENTIONED SINCE THE COURT'S
ACTION HAS IMPLICATIONS ON ALL
THREE OF OUR SEGMENTS BECAUSE
THAT STATUTE ON LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS IS A
REQUIREMENT. PLACED ON. ALL
CAMPUSES COMMITTEE COLLEGES
CSU'S EMERGENCIES. THAT ARE.
THIS BILL IS ALSO DESIGNED TO
PREVENT SIMILAR CAPS ON ANY
OTHER CAMPUSES STUDENT
ENROLLMENT IN THE FUTURE. IT
ALSO ALIGNS THE STATUTE WITH OUR
THE LEGISLATURE'S LONG STANDING
POLICY TO EXPAND RATHER THAN
REDUCE STUDENT ACCESS TO PUBLIC
IRE TO HIGHER EDUCATION. LET ME
DESCRIBE SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE
BILL DOES IT MODIFIES THE
LANGUAGE IN OUR PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE RELATED TO LRT PEAS THAT'S
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLANS BY
REMOVING THE SENTENCE THAT
SINGLED OUT STUDENT ENROLLMENT
WHILE RETAINING THE REQUIREMENT.
THE PUBLIC HERE TO HIGHER
EDUCATION CAMPUSES WOULD PREPARE
A LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT. FULL
RANGE OF ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
NO I SPECIFY THAT BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT AN EXEMPTION UNDER SECRET
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT IT L. R.
D. P. THAT IS EXEMPTED IT IS
RATHER THAT WE ARE NOT FREE OR
DENYING THAT STUDENT ENROLLMENT
MAY IN AND OF ITSELF BE THE
HIGHEST ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
OVER ANY OTHER OF THE
ACTIVITIES. IN OUR PROJECTS OR
POPULATIONS ENGAGED IN THE
CAMPUS. SO IN THE EVENT THAT A
COURT FINES. WELL IT IT USUALLY
DOES THE BILL IT CLARIFIES THAT
ENROLLMENT CHANGES BY THEMSELVES
DO NOT CONSTITUTE A SEPARATE
PROJECT UNDER SECRET AND THAT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED. THE LINE IN THAT
STATUTE AND THE STATUTE AS A
WHOLE HAS BEEN IN EFFECT FOR
THIRTY YEARS AND YET WE HAVE
NEVER HAD A COURT ST. THAT
STUDENT ROMAN ALONE IS A PROJECT
UNDER SECRET OUR STATUTE MAKES
THE L. R. D. P. A. PROJECT UNDER
SECRET. SO IN THE EVENT THAT A
COURT FINDS THE CAMPUS'S
ACTIVITIES ARE IN VIOLATION OF
THE CAMPUSES LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN IT ALLOWS THE
COURT TO ORDER THE CAMPUS. TO
PREPARE ADDITIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS INCLUDING UP TO A FULL
ER IF THE COURT DETERMINES THAT
THE INCREASES IN CAMPUS
POPULATION. EXCEEDS THE
PRODUCTION PROJECTIONS ADOPTED
IN THE MOST RECENT L. R. D. P.
AND ANALYZED IN THE SUPPORTING.
ENVIRONMENTAL MATERIALS. IT
PROVIDES EIGHTEEN MONTHS FOR THE
CAMPUS AFFECTED TO CERTIFY A NEW
E. I. R. OR THE NEW ANALYSIS
BEFORE THE COURT IS AUTHORIZED.
TO ENJOIN INCREASES IN CAMPUS
POPULATION THAT EXCEEDS THE
PROJECTIONS. AND IT SPECIFIES
THAT ANY INJUNCTION OR JUDGMENT
IN EFFECT AS OF THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF THIS BILL THAT IMPACT
STUDENT ENROLLMENT ARE
UNENFORCEABLE. AND IT SPECIFIES
THAT THE CHANGES TO THE STATUTE
THAT WE WOULD BE MAKING IN SP
ONE EIGHTEEN ARE RETROACTIVE.
NOW AS I STATED PREVIOUSLY THE
CHANGES ARE DESIGNED TO ENABLE
UC BERKELEY TO EXTENDED MISSIONS
OFFERS AS PLANNED FOR THIS
COMING FALL. AARON TO PROTECT OR
PUBLIC CARRIAGE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES FROM SIMILAR ISSUES
IN THE FUTURE. AND I WANT TO
THANK THE PART TIME STAFF OR
BUDGET STAFF DECEMBER IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ENGAGED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND I ASK FOR YOUR
I. VOTE ON SB ONE EIGHTEEN.
MADAM PRO TEM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE EIGHTEEN- A
LITTLE OVER A WEEK AGO WE WERE
PRESENTED WITH AN IMMENSE
CHALLENGE- CERTAINLY AS THE
BUDGETEERS INDICATED WITH ALL
JUDICIAL RECOURSE EXHAUSTED IN
COLLEGE ACCEPTANCE LETTERS SET
TO GO OUT. OVER TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED INCOMING UC BERKELEY
STUDENTS WERE AT RISK OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO ATTEND ONE OF OUR
NATION'S VERY BEST PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES NEXT FALL. AND I
WANNA IN PARTICULAR SPEAK ON
THIS AND TAKE A MOMENT BECAUSE I
REALLY WANT TO FOCUS- THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE BILL'S
AUTHOR THE SENATOR FROM BERKELEY
FOR HER INCREDIBLE WORK WRITING
A BILL THAT WILL SINGLE HANDEDLY
CHANGED THE DIRECTION OF SO MANY
OF OUR STATE'S MOST ACCOMPLISHED
STUDENTS. AND ENSURE THAT THEIR
DREAMS ARE NOT DE RAIL. SINCE
THE SUPREME COURT DECISION. THE
SENATOR FROM BERKLEY WORK
RELENTLESSLY AROUND THE CLOCK
GOING BACK AND FORTH WITH
ATTORNEYS AND STAFF FOR
COUNTLESS HOURS. EVERY TIME A
ROAD BLOCK WAS PUT UP SHE
REFUSED TO TAKE NO FOR AN ANSWER
AND KEPT WORKING UNTIL A
SOLUTION WAS FOUND. AND THEN SHE
PUT PEN TO PAPER HERSELF. SB ONE
EIGHTEEN IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF
THE LEGISLATURE ACTING QUICKLY
TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS ARE PUT
FIRST. AND AHEAD OF A NARROW SET
OF INTEREST. AND I DON'T USUALLY
DO THIS BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- SOMETIMES TO REALLY
ACKNOWLEDGE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
DOES THE LION'S SHARE OF WORK.
AND I APPRECIATED I THINK THIS
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND I
URGE YOUR I'VE BUILT ON THIS
BILL. SENATOR NIELSEN. BUT A
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
OF THE SENATE I AGREE WITH THE
PRO TEN THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. AND I WILL SUPPORT FOR
THE STUDENTS. BUT NOT FOR YOU
SEE. HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
DECADES HAS OVER AND ROLLED AND
ENROLLED LARGER NUMBERS OF OUT
OF STATE STUDENTS FOR THE SAKE
OF MONEY. NOT POLICY MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT IT IS ABOUT
MONEY FOR THE UNIVERSITY. THAT
SOMETIMES THOUGH NOT ALWAYS
RESULTS IN QUALITY EDUCATION.
AND MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR-
ATTENDEES I WON'T SAY OUR YOUTH
. BUT OUR ATTENDEES THAT IN
ITSELF IS GOOD. THE MODIFICATION
OF SICK ONE AND IT'S INTERESTING
TO HEAR SOME OF THE- YOU SEE
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT SECRET REFORM
NOW IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THEM. MOST OF THE TIME THEY DO
NOTHING BUT OPPOSE ANY SICK
PERFORM FOR OTHER. ENDEAVORS AND
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S MY POINT WE NEED A BROAD
DEEP SLEEPER REFORM NOT PICKING
AROUND THE EDGES AS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE FOR SPORTS
STADIUMS FOR EXAMPLE. I ARGUE
THAT THAT THAT'S NOT A GOOD USE
. FOR SPORTS STADIUMS THAT HELP
SOMEBODY OUT MAYBE SURE TO KEEP
THE TEAM IN TOWN MAYBE. THAT'S
NOT THE BROKEN PORTENT USE. THE
FRONT. IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
IT IS A GOOD USE BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS THAT WILL NOW BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION. BECAUSE OF. BECAUSE
OF A SHORTAGE COURT DECISION
MAYBE. BUT I'VE LEARNED OVER THE
YEARS NOT TO BE SO CRITICAL OF
COURT DECISIONS. MANY OF THEM I
HAVE OPPOSED OVER THE DECADES
MMHM LOCAL LEVEL COURT DECISIONS
THE US SUPREME COURT DECISIONS
ON MANY OCCASIONS. THAT COURT
MADE A INDEPENDENT DECISION. THE
RIGHT DECISION CERTAINLY NOT FOR
A LOT OF STUDENTS. NOT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY AS WELL. AND IN THAT
RESPECT I URGE A NO VOTE.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I FULLY-
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE AND I ALSO WANNA ECHO ON
THE PRETENCE REMARKS AND EXPRESS
MY DEEP GRATITUDE- TO THE
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY FOR HER
EXTRAORDINARY LEADERSHIP-
BECAUSE OF HER LEADERSHIP AND
THE COLLABORATIVE EFFORT HERE
THOUSANDS OF LIVES OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WILL BE BETTER SO THANK
YOU- COLLEAGUES THE LAWSUIT THAT
LED UP TO THIS ARBITRARY- COP OF
UC BERKELEY'S AND ROMAN- WILL
HARM THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE SIMPLY
TRYING. TO GET AN EDUCATION AND
THIS EMERGENCY TRIAGE
LEGISLATION WILL SOLVE THAT
IMMEDIATE PROBLEM. BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO ASK OURSELVES HOW WE GOT
HERE. HOW ON EARTH DID OUR
SYSTEM OF LAW IN CALIFORNIA
ENABLE PEOPLE TO USE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW. TO DICTATE
HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE ALLOWED TO
ATTEND UC CAMPUS. THE ANSWER IS
THAT TRAGICALLY A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
SYKORA. HAS BEEN DISTORTED BUT
BEYOND RECOGNITION TO EMPOWER
ANYONE WITH ENOUGH MONEY TO HIRE
A LAWYER TO DELAY OR BLOCK EVEN
THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE PROJECTS. THE TRAIN
WRECK THAT WE'RE RESOLVING TODAY
AT BERKELEY WAS VERY HIGH
PROFILE AND MADE HEADLINES
EVERYWHERE. BUT LET'S BE CLEAR
THAT WHAT HAPPENED AT BERKELEY.
WAS NOT EVEN REMOTELY UNIQUE.
WHAT HAPPENED AT BERKELEY
HAPPENS EVERY DAY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA NOT IN WAYS TO
GENERATE NATIONAL HEADLINES ARE
LOTS OF TWITTER TRAFFIC'S. NOT
IN WAYS TO GET THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE RILED UP BUT A MUCH
QUIETER SMALLER WAYS. THAT
DEEPLY HARM OUR STATE. IN MANY
WAYS TRAGICALLY SEE WHAT IS THE
LAW THAT SWALLOWED CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION THE SEQUEL BEING
USED TO ARBITRARILY CAPPED YOU
SEE IN ROMAN SEQUEL HAS BEEN
USED TO STOP OR DELAY BIKE LANES
IT'S BEEN USED TO STOP OR DELAY
TRAINS AND OTHER PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. IT'S BEEN USED
TO STOP CLEAN ENERGY PROJECTS
IT'S BEEN USED TO STOP APARTMENT
BUILDINGS LITERALLY RIGHT NEXT
TO A TRAIN STATION. THESE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE ALL GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. THESE HELP REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS AND YES SECRET
TRAGICALLY HAS BEEN REGULARLY
USE TO STOP OR THE LADIES
CLIMATE FRIENDLY PROJECTS. HOW
COULD THAT BE AND THE ANSWER IS
THAT WHEN SIEGEL WAS WRITTEN
FIFTY PLUS YEARS AGO. CLIMATE
CHANGE WAS NOT THE FOCUS OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFORTS. SEQUEL
WAS CREATED WHEN ANY AND ALL
DEVELOPMENT WAS CONSIDERED BAD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT. WHEN
POPULATION GROWTH WAS CONSIDERED
THE TOP ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT
WHEN LIMITING GROWTH IN CITIES
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO AND BERKELEY
AND SANTA MONICA WAS CONSIDERED
PRO ENVIRONMENT. BUT WE NOW KNOW
THAT THAT APPROACH MAKING IT
HARDER IMPOSSIBLE TO BUILD
ANYTHING ANYWHERE NO MATTER HOW
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE
ACTUALLY FUELS CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND AS A RESULT BY ALLOWING
NYONE WHO CAN HIRE A LAWYER TO
BLOCK THINGS LIKE INFILL HOUSING
TRANSIT AND CLEAN ENERGY SEE
WHAT TRAGICALLY IS USED AND
ABUSED IN A WAY THAT HELPS FUEL
CLIMATE CHANGE. WHEN C. QUEST
USED TO STOP DENSE URBAN INFILL
DEVELOPMENTS. THE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD HAVE LIVED IN THOSE
APARTMENTS THEY DON'T EVAPORATE
THEY'RE GONNA LIVE FURTHER AWAY
WHERE THEY HAVE TO DRIVE MORE
AND MORE CARBON EMISSIONS. ONE
SEQUEL IS USED TO STOP
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS PEOPLE ARE JUST GOING
TO DRIVE MORE. WHEN C. WAS USED
TO BLOCK STUDENTS FROM ENROLLING
AT UC BERKELEY A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO DRIVE VERY
MUCH. THEY'RE JUST GOING TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE WHERE THEY HAVE
TO DRIVE MORE THAN CARBON
EMISSIONS GO UP. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR SEQUEL IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT LAW I DO NOT AGREE
WITH THOSE WHO SAY THAT IT
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED OR REPEALED
THAT WOULD BE A BAD. IDEA SEQUEL
HAS DONE MANY GOOD THINGS IN
TERMS OF SLOWING DOWN OR%
STOPPING PROJECTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY BAD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND THAT NEEDS TO
CONTINUE. BUT I DO AGREE THAT
SICK ONE NEEDS TO BE MODERNIZED
SO THAT IT IS INTENSELY FOCUSED.
ON CLIMATE ACTION. THAT IS WHY
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION IS ABOUT
TODAY. AND THAT IS WHAT WE NEED
TO SEE WHAT TO BE A TOOL TO
ACHIEVE. SO LET'S PASS THIS
MEASURE TODAY LET'S LET THE
STUDENTS GET AN EDUCATION. BUT
LET'S NOT THINK FOR A MINUTE
THAT THIS MESS WAS SOMEHOW AN
ANOMALY. WHEN IT COMES TO SEE
WHAT THIS UC BERKELEY TRAIN
WRECK ISN'T A BUG. IT'S A
FEATURE I ASKED FOR AN AIBO.
SYNERGY. ONE AT MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
EIGHTEEN AS SOMEONE WHO'S WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE US
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AND STUDENTS APPLYING TO
THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM I KNOW
WHAT AN ADMISSIONS DECISION
MEANS TO MANY I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO COMPLETE AN ONLINE
APPLICATION I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO WRITE A COLLEGE ESSAY
I'VE EDITED HUNDREDS IN MY LIFE
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO GO
THROUGH THE FINANCIAL AID
PROCESS WITH THE DREAM AND HOPE
OF GOING TO HIRE AND- I BELIEVE
THAT THE STUDENTS TODAY NOT JUST
FOR UC BERKELEY BUT STUDENTS
ACROSS ALL THREE OF OUR SYSTEMS
UC CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEMS. WILL BENEFIT FROM OUR
APPROACH. BUT ALTHOUGH I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF TODAY'S BILL I DO
WANT TO INSURE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE. IF THE
UNIVERSITIES DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH SEA QUEST FOR INCREASED
ENROLLMENT THERE HAVE GOT TO BE
ALTERNATIVES TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENT HOUSING IS ADDRESSED. I
WORK WITH TOO MANY STUDENTS WHO
ARE LIVING IN CARS WHO ARE COUCH
SURFING WHO ARE LIVING IN HOTELS
NOT JUST ON MY UNIVERSITY CAMPUS
BUT ON UNIVERSITY CAMPUS IN MANY
OF OUR DISTRICTS. AND THERE IS
JUST SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH STUDENT
HOUSING. THIS IMPACTS THEIR
ACADEMICS IT IMPACTS OUR OVERALL
WELL BEING AND IT IMPACTS THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE. THE STUDENT
HOUSING CRISIS HAS AN IMPACT ON
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT STUDENT HOUSING
IS ADEQUATE THAT IT'S HEALTHY
AND THAT IT'S SAFE. THE UC'S
MUST ADDRESS THE ENROLLMENT
ISSUE. NEW LEGISLATION TODAY WE
DON'T WANT TO DISREGARD THE
ESTABLISHED PROCESS WE KNOW THAT
OUR UNIVERSITIES NEW BUT
GUIDELINES AND REQUIREMENTS WE
ALSO HAVE UNIVERSITIES THAT HAVE
A LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLANS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO KEEP
UP WITH THEM. AND WILE WE TRIED
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM FOR
STUDENTS WE ALSO CANNOT LEAVE
OUR COMMUNITIES BEHIND AND WE
CANNOT. LEAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO JUST THE LEGISLATURE. OUR
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION MUST
BE PARTNERS IN SHARING THIS
RESPONSIBILITY. THANK YOU SIS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALSO NEED
TO FIND A WAY TO WORK MORE
CLOSELY TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION. NOT JUST THE
SITUATION IN FRONT OF US BUT THE
ONGOING ISSUES THAT ENROLLMENT
WILL BRING TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO OUR CITIES TO OUR
COUNTIES TO ALL OF OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES. AND I VOTED TODAY
DOES NOT NEGATE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
AND OUR COMMUNITY'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL IMPACT OUR
UNIVERSITIES WITH INCREASED
ENROLLMENT. WITH THAT MEMBERS I
DO HOPE THAT WE SUPPORT THIS BUT
I DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
ONGOING ISSUES THAT WILL BE
PRESENTED TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. VETR
LOWERED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I'M NOT- LET ME SAY FIRST IT
ALONG WITH EVERYONE ELSE THE
BUDGET CHAIR AND EVERYONE ELSE
THAT WORKED ON THIS GETS
TREMENDOUS CREDIT BECAUSE THERE
WAS A VERY UNIQUE CALL OUT IN
THE LAW HAD CITED ENROLLMENT AND
TURNED IT INTO A PROJECT THAT
SHOULD NEVER BE THAT WAS AN OVER
REACH THE STUDENTS THAT WERE
POTENTIALLY DENIED SHOULD NOT BE
DENIED THIS FIXES IT AND I'M
GOING TO BE PROUD TO VOTE FOR
IT- IN A MINUTE. I THINK THERE'S
A NUANCE HERE BECAUSE MANY OF
THE SPEECHES HAVE BEEN GIVEN
COMPLETELY. ABOUT SEQUEL. AND
YET IF- AND I KNOW I SAID THIS
IN THE BUDGET HEARING THIS
MORNING. HI I WAS ONCE MAYOR OF
A TOWN THAT HOSTS A UNIVERSITY
THAT IS A CITY OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND INSIDE OF SIXTY
THOUSAND PERSON CITY. THEN THERE
IS A COMPLETE AND TOTAL
CONSTITUTIONAL EXEMPTION FROM
ANY LOCAL LAND USE ANY LOCAL
TAXES AND FEES ANY LOCAL
RESIDENTS OF REGULATION OF ANY
KIND. SO WHEN EXAMPLES OF TRAIN
HOUSING BALL PARKS ARE ARE
RAISED THOSE ALL HAVE PROCESSES
THEY GO THROUGH THE NORMAL ORDER
OF THINGS NONE OF THEM HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL EXEMPTION FROM
LAND USE REVIEW. YOU SEE DOGS
AND SO IF YOU. ARE THE SENATOR
FROM SANTA BARBARA THE JUST
SPOKE THERE WAS A HUGE DORM WITH
NO WINDOWS ON A COASTAL BLUFF.
THAT DESERVES TO GO THROUGH SOME
FORM OF LAND USE IT IN SANTA
CRUZ WE ARE NOW IN A HIGH FIRE
SO THE ENTIRE CAMPUS WAS
EVACUATED IN THE CZ YOU FIRE THE
FIRE THAT TOOK NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE HOUSES MADE IT TO
THE UPPER REACHES. OF THE CAMPUS
THIS IS TRUE ACROSS THE STATE
THAT IS WHY THE ISSUE OF UC IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE REST OF THEM.
AND THE NEEDLE WAS THREADED HERE
THE LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN
STILL ARE SUBJECT TO SPEAKER AND
THAT IS TOTALLY APPROPRIATE.
HAVING THEM SUBJECT TO NO LAND
USE REGULATION OF ANY KIND WOULD
BE A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING. AND I AM HOPING THAT
EVERYONE THAT IS SO STRONGLY
BEHIND THIS JOINS US IN DOING
THE STEPS WE HAVE TO DO. WE
APPROPRIATED TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR HOUSING AT HIGHER EDUCATION
LAST YEAR SIX HUNDRED MILLION
GOES TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. IT WAS DESIGNED TO
BE OVER MULTIPLE YEARS IT IS
ALREADY OVERSUBSCRIBED. WE HAVE
TO DO MORE. LAST YEAR WE DID A
CAP BUT THE THREE CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE THE LARGEST NUMBER OF OUT
OF STATE STUDENTS. SO PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN PAYING TAXES IN
THE STATE. CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR KIDS CAN GET INTO A
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA CAMPUS.
AND IN OUR BUDGET HEARING THIS
YEAR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BEFORE WE EVEN KNEW
THIS LAWSUIT WAS OUT THERE. WE
BASICALLY SAID TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. YOU CAN'T JUST BE
JAMMING MORE STUDENTS ON EVERY
CAMPUS YOU HAVE TO HAVE PLANS
FOR ADDITIONAL CAMPUSES. FOR
CENTERS FOR WAYS THAT WE CAN
APPROPRIATELY TAKE THE GROWTH
THAT WE WANT AND WE NEED AND ONE
OF THE FINEST PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS IN THE WORLD. SO I JUST
HOPE. THAT THERE'S JUST A
RECOGNITION THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IS A UNIQUE
SITUATION. AND HAVING SAID THAT-
THIS NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN AND
WALMART CALLED OUT AS A PROJECT
AND I HOPE EVERYBODY SUPPORTS
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY. SENATOR
WRESTLE. THANK YOU MAN PRESENT I
THINK SOME COMMENTS ARE MADE
THAT ARE ARE EXCELLENT I JUST
WANTED TO BRIEFLY OUT ON TO THEM
BECAUSE I THINK THIS BILL IS
VERY IMPORTANT IN ADDRESSING A
PART PROBLEM THAT- MAKE IT WORSE
AND UNFORTUNATELY- OF THEIR
ACTIONS BEING TAKEN TO COUNTER
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
UNIVERSITIES WHICH ARE SECOND TO
NONE IN THE NATION. AND I THINK
HAVE LED TO HELP CREATE SOME OF
THE WEALTHIEST NEIGHBORHOODS IN
OUR STATE I MEAN ARE YOU KNOW IF
YOU LOOK AT WHERE OUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE LOCATED THEY
TEND TO BE LOCATED IN WEALTHY
NEIGHBORHOODS AND WHEN THEY WERE
FIRST SIGHTED THEY WEREN'T
WEALTHY NEIGHBORHOODS AND WHAT
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE WHY ARE OUR
OUR UNIVERSITIES LOCATION
CONTRIBUTING TO MORE INVESTMENT
IN THOSE AREAS AND BETTER
HOUSING I WENT TO UCLA. I KNOW
IT'S A HARD THING FOR ME TO FIND
OFF CAMPUS HOUSING BECAUSE I WAS
SURROUNDED BY OUR UNIVERSITY
TRYING TO BUY A BELLAIRE AND
WEST LA AND BEVERLY HILLS SO
WHERE STUDENTS CAN LIVE I HAD TO
LIVE IN A VAN OFF CAMPUS- RIDING
MY BIKE TO WORK BECAUSE I
COULDN'T EVEN PARK MY VAN CLOSE
TO THE CAMPUS BECAUSE OF PERMIT
PARKING. PENCIL AND RIGHT NOW
OUTSIDE OF UCLA. ONE OF THE-
MOST EXPENSIVE HOMES IN ALL OF
THE UNITED STATES IS CURRENTLY
LISTED FOR SALE. SO WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU CONSIDER WHAT THESE
UNIVERSITIES TO FURTHER
SURROUNDING AREAS THEY TEND TO
HAVE. LOTS OF VEHICLES WITH
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY SO NO
EMISSIONS LIKE I KNOW UCSD UCLA
ARE DOING I KNOW. BERKELEY HAS
SIMILAR PROGRAMS ALL OUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE LEADERS IN
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY. IN OUR ARE
REDUCING THEIR CARBON FOOTPRINT.
ARE PROVIDING STUDENT
TRANSPORTATION ON SITE IN OUR
CAMPUSES BUT LET'S FACE IT. ON
OUR CAMPUSES WHERE STUDENTS MOST
LIKELY TO DO WALK. OR RIDE A
BICYCLE. CAN WE TALK ABOUT IT
VARMINT OLYMPIC. I THINK SEQUEL
IS BEING ABUSED. I THINK WE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING TO CURB THIS
WITH REGARD TO OUR UNIVERSITIES.
UCSD A LAWSUIT BLOCKED THE
CREATION OF A HILLEL HOUSE. THAT
ACTUALLY HAD ENVIRONMENTAL THAT
PRETTY MUCH LIMITED OR
ELIMINATED THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. AND THE PEOPLE SUING
DIDN'T LIVE ON PROPERTIES THAT
DID THE SAME THING. HOW WAS THAT
EVEN SURE. THEY BLOCKED THE
INTRODUCTION OF A OF A TROLLEY
LINE THAT WOULD'VE BROUGHT OF
YOU KNOW. ALLOWED STUDENTS TO
COME IN WITHOUT HAVING TO DRIVE
INTO THE NEIGHBORHOOD. THEY
ALLOW THE- THEY BLOCKED THE
CREATION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR STUDENTS. THIS IS JUST AN
ABUSE OF THE LAW. BUT WHAT IS IT
THE EFFECT IT CAN HAVE AN
ARGUMENT OR OR UNIVERSITIES. TO
REDUCING THE COMPETITIVENESS
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT POPULATION IN
UNIVERSITY IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY TRANSLATE TO A
REDUCTION. IN QUALITY OF
EDUCATION UCLA IS THE MOST
POPULATED UNIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT IS THE NUMBER
ONE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY IN THE
NATION WITH THE HIGHEST. AMOUNT
OF RESEARCH DOLLARS. BEING IN.
IN ALL OF THE UNIVERSITIES OF
CALIPHS. SO I THINK THERE'S AN
ARGUMENT THAT THESE UNIVERSITIES
HAVE A BENEFICIAL IMPACT ON
NEIGHBORHOODS INCLUDING
PROVIDING FACILITIES AND ACCESS
TO SERVICES AND OFTEN- A TOP
RATE OF CULTURAL EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES TO THE NAME NEIGHBORING
MEMBERS. BUT THEY ALSO PROVIDE
THE- AN AMAZING JOB ENGINE AND A
SOURCE OF NEW INNOVATIVE IDEAS
FOR CALIFORNIA AND I THINK IT'S
TIME- WE DID SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS I JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HARD WORK MY COLLEAGUES IN
BUDGET AND- THE CENTER FOR
BERKELEY WHO HAS TAKEN THE SONG
AND I HOPE THIS. WILL APPLY
EQUALLY TO ALL OUR UNIVERSITIES
AND WHEN WE START TO LOOK AT
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN BUILD HOUSING
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
BECAUSE CURRENTLY IF YOU'RE A
STUDENT ONE OF OUR UNIVERSITIES
OFTEN TIME. OFF ON CAMPUS
HOUSING IS MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
OFF CAMPUS HOUSING AND WE NEED
TO CORRECT THAT AS WELL THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTERS SCANNER
YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR MADAM PRESIDENT- THE
RISK OF- CHEATING MYSELF- I
THINK SOME SUN MAYBE ONLY A FEW
OF US WILL REMEMBER THEIR
CARTOON POGO WHERE THE LINE WAS
WE HAVE MET THE ENEMY AND IT IS
US AND I THINK IN MUCH OF WHAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED HERE WE COULD
LOOK AT THE FACT THAT FOR
EXAMPLE. I ATTENDED UC BERKELEY
SOME FORTY FIVE OR SO YEARS AGO
AND AT THE TIME THE POPULATION
IN CALIFORNIA WAS HALF OR EVEN
LESS THAN HALF OF IT IS TODAY
SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE ONLY ADDED
ONE UC CAMPUS SO WE HAVE DOUBLED
. OUR POPULATION THE STATE ONE
CAMPUS YET OUR MASTER PLAN A
PIRATE SAYS THAT WE WILL
PROVIDE. THE SUPPORT FOR ALL
QUALIFIED STUDENTS. NOW WE'VE
ADDED A FEW MORE SEE ISSUES BUT
AGAIN WE LOOK AT OUR POPULATION
WE'VE NOT ADDED THAT MANY. AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SITUATION OF
PERHAPS THE UNIVERSITY'S.
INCREASING THEIR ENROLLMENT OF
STUDENTS TO PAY MORE STUDENTS
WHO ARE OUT OF STATE. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT OUR- THE LEGISLATURE'S
FUNDING. OF OUR CAMPUSES AND YOU
GO BACK OVER A TEN TWENTY YEAR
PERIOD UNTIL THE LAST FOUR
YEARS. THE PROPORTION THAT THEY
RECEIVED FROM THE STATE AS
COMPARED TO. EITHER OF THEIR
TUITION OR ARE THERE OTHER ALL
KINDS OF OTHER EXTERNAL SOURCES
WHICH GREATLY OUT OF PROPORTION
SO IN OTHER WORDS WE USED TO
FIND. OUR UC SYSTEM AS A WHOLE.
MUCH HIGHER PERCENTAGE. AND THUS
WE MORALLY HAD MUCH MORE OF A
RIGHT TO LIMIT HOW MANY OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS NOW WE ARE DOING
SO BY BACK FILLING THOSE- THAT
FUNDING SO WE ARE DOING THAT.
AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TO THE
HOUSING CRISIS. OBVIOUSLY OUR
CAMPUSES WHETHER CSU'S COMMITTEE
COLLEGES OR YOU SEASON WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE STUDENTS IN ALL
THREE SEGMENTS WERE LIVING IN
CARS NOW WERE WITHOUT SHELTER.
NONE OF OUR SEGMENTS HAVE
PROVIDED ENOUGH HOUSING NINE BUT
AT THE SAME TIME NONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE EITHER. AND IF
WE LOOK AT MY PARTICULAR. TOWN
AND I STAYED IN BERKELEY AFTER
GRADUATING FROM UC INVALID THERE
EVER SINCE MY OWN TOWN. PASSED A
VOTER INITIATIVE THAT PREVENTED
THE BUILDING OF ANY MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING FOR DECADES THEY PASS
THAT IN MY SECOND YEAR AT CAL.
SO NOT ONLY SO WE CAN SAY YES
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA- C. H. U.
R. C. C. C. YOU BETTER BUILD ON
MORE HOUSING HOWEVER WE HAVE TO
TELL THE COMMUNITIES ALSO.
BECAUSE THE HOUSING. ALL OF OUR
MAKE. IT SHOULD NOT BE ON THE
BACKS OF STUDENTS ALONE SO SP
ONE EIGHTEEN DOES NOT FIX ALL
THOSE PROBLEMS BY ANY MEANS NOR
DOES IT ELIMINATE THE POPULATION
AND OF COURSE STUDENTS ARE PART
OF A CAMPUS POPULATION SO THEY
WILL STILL HAVE TO BE EVALUATED
AS EVERY OTHER ASPECT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THE
CAMPUS WHICH IS WHAT S. B. EIGHT
ONE EIGHTEEN. IS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE NOT ONLY CHIEF I GET
THAT RIGHT BALANCE THAT ALL OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AND
NOT A PARTICULAR WAY SO WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE ON SB
ONE EIGHTEEN AND I WANT TO GET
AN EXPRESS MY DEEP APPRECIATION
THE PRO TEM STAFF WERE
PHENOMENAL IN THIS EFFORT AS
WELL AS THE BUDGET STAFF AND SO
MANY MORE AND OUR- WHOLE HOUSE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION SO
PRECIADO IN AND YES ON SB
EIGHTEEN. ONE EIGHTEEN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ADKINS. BAIT
BACKER HI FORTUS BRADFORD I HAVE
I EVER HI PROTESTING I DALLY I
THOUGHT I TORONTO I EGGMAN I
LASER EYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO HI HER TADO
. JONES. I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LLEVA THE MON I WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. HI A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM I PERSON TINA I BROUGHT FIVE
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN HI
NUMBER FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI.
FIVE WINNERS I WILL HI PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. ATKINS
BASED. PORCHES GROSS. HER TADO.
LAVER MELINDA'S. FIVE THIRTY
THREE NO ZERO THE MET THE-
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SIX SENATOR SKINNER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL ONE NINETEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO THE
STATE BUDGET AND MAKING A
PERFORATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELL
CENTRE SKINNER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANKS SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT SP ONE NINETEEN IS THE
BUT JUNIOR DEMANDS CURRENT
BUDGET ACT AND IT RE
APPROPRIATES FUNDING FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE TO CONTINUE
TO BE USED FOR ITS ORIGINAL
PURPOSE. IT ALLOWS FUNDS FOR THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING POST TO
BE TRANSFERRED BETWEEN BUDGET
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
MEET STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS AND
IT MAKES OTHER TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES THE BILL IS
PRIMARILY TECHNICAL IN NATURE
AND DOES NOT RESULT IN NEW COSTS
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
NELSON. SENATE PRESIDENT LATER
GENTLENESS AND URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS. AGAIN IT'S NECESSARY FOR
THE BUDGET I SUPPOSE. BUT IT'S
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE EXCESSES
. OF THIS LEGISLATION. WE ARE.
AUTHORIZING PROJECTS IN PAST
BUDGET TO BE PAID FOR IN FUTURE
BUDGETS. AMONG OTHER THINGS
THAT'S GETTING TO BE A HABIT NOW
. AND I THINK IT'S A DECEPTIVE
HABIT NOT GOOD FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT ALSO
PROVIDES MONEY TO DO SOMETHING
THAT MANY OF US OPPOSED.
DECERTIFICATION THE POLICE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS. THAT
WAS PASSED NOW WE'RE GONNA PAY
THE PRICE. THE PART OF THE
PRICES. COMPROMISED OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND NOW WE'RE GONNA
FIND IN THIS LEGISLATION. IT
CIRCUMVENTS OUR NORMAL
PROCEDURES WHICH AGAIN THE
LEGISLATURE IS GET IN THE HABIT
OF DOING WHERE WE HAVE. AT LEAST
TWO POLICY COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
TWO FISCAL COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
AND NOW WE'VE BECOME USED TO
FAST TRACKING THINGS I DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOOD FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. I DON'T THINK
THEY LIKE IT IF THEY KNEW ABOUT
IT AND THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THE PRESS DOESN'T EVEN
MAKE AN ISSUE OF IT ANYMORE.
BLOCK NO BIG DEAL. SO MANY
THINGS HAVE. HAPPENED ARE
HAPPENING HERE. THAT CUT OUT.
THE PUBLIC THE DIVORCE CITIZEN
INPUT. FROM THE INPUT THAT WE
DESERVE LEGISLATORS ON THEIR
BEHALF. ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS HOW
WE DEAL WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS NOW. PUBLIC COMMENT
USED TO TRULY BE PUBLIC COMMENT
PEOPLE COULD COME AND COMMENT
AND SAY WHAT THEY WANTED TO SAY
. NOW WE'VE LIMITED THAT EVEN IN
FLOOR DEBATE. TO THE MEMBERS
PRESENTING THE BILL THEN MAYBE
ONE OTHER ORDERS TO ALL TO
POSSIBLY. THAT EVERYBODY ELSE
ALL THEY GET TO DO IS SAY I'M
FORD AND I'M AGAINST. NOW I
SUGGESTED WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
THAT HABIT WE SIMPLY HAVE THE.
OPERATOR OF THE PHONE SYSTEM.
TAKE A POLL. BY PEOPLE CALLED IN
FOR TEN AGAINST. THAT'S ALL
THAT'S WORTH BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
GETTING ANY MEANINGFUL PUBLIC
INPUT. FOR THOSE REASONS I URGE
A NO VOTE. THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SAYING MAN SENATOR
SKINNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
BASED. BACKER HI FOR JUST
BRADFORD I HAVE A I PROTESTING
HI DOLLY. DOT. FIVE ZERO SEVEN
FIVE EIGHT MEN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE MY GROW. HERTZBERG
HI WHERE SO HI FURTADO. JONES NO
KIM WALKER I LAYERED HI LABOUR
LIMO I WIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH NO PAM HI FORTUNE TINA. HI
RALPH I RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN
I AM BERG HI FI CASKEY I WINNER
. I WILL KNOW. IT'S REALLY UP TO
MEMBERS. ATKINS BAYTEX FOR JUST
. VALLEY. GROVE NO HER TADO.
LABOUR MELINDA'S NO. RECOGNITION
BY THE TWENTY EIGHT NOTRE SIXTY
SEVEN MINUTES ARE CONCURRED IN.
BEIJING OVER THE CENTRE GLAZER
PURPOSE DERIVED- I GUESS YOU
DIDN'T SEE MY HANDS- BUT I HAD A
SERIOUS PROCEDURAL ISSUE WITH
THE LAST- MATTER- PERMISSION TO
USE A PROPER. PERMISSION GRANTED. WITHOUT OBJECTION. HE'S ME
PERMISSION TO READ. WITHOUT
OBJECTION- UNDER THE SENATE
RULES. TWENTY EIGHT POINT ONE
ZERO. SAYS THAT DISPLAY BILL
SHOULD NOT BE HEARD OR ACTED
UPON IN ANY COMMITTEE VOTED ON
BY THE SENATE. FOR PURPOSES OF
THIS RULE. A DISPLAY BUILT ME
THE BILL THAT SETS FORTH
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES. IN ADDITION
TO EXISTING LAW. AND I THINK WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THIS LAST
MATTER VIOLATION OF RULE TWENTY
EIGHT POINT TEN. WITH ALL
RESPECT. SITUATION IN ANOTHER
APARTMENT INCREASE ARE NOT
ALLOWED ON THE PRESIDING.
OFFICERS FIRST DAY AND- I HAVE
THE RULES HERE COULD YOU- POINT
TO WHERE THAT IS IN THE RULES I
HAVE THE WHOLE BOOK HERE. I HAD
A WHOLE BOOK IN THE BACK
SOMEWHERE I BELIEVE- CAN I. CAN
I LIKE TO APPEAL THE RULING OF
THE CHAIR. AND I GUESS FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE WILL RESPECT.
RESPECTFULLY O. ENVIA IT'S
APPARENTLY IT'S AM WELL AS I AM
AWARE OF IT SAID REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION AND NOT APPEALABLE
THANK YOU WHAT ABOUT RULE TWENTY
EIGHT POINT EIGHT. WELL OF
COURSE YOU KNOW THAT'S FOR THE
FISCAL COMMITTEES APPROPRIATIONS
USEFUL OR WHAT WHAT ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT POINT NINE. THAT IS ALSO
FOR THE PHYSICAL. IT IS
APPROPRIATION USE EVERYWHERE IS
THAT SUBJECT TO APPEAL. NO THAT
WOULD NOT ADD A RECONSIDERATION
. NO THANK YOU I OBJECT HELLO
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER THANK
YOU SENATOR IS- I GOT A CENTER
FOR GENOME. I HAVE AN EASIER
QUESTION DOES SHE COULD IMPACT
MARCH MADNESS. NO IT DOESN'T.
WE'LL BE PROCEEDING FORWARD WITH
A TOURNAMENT SHORTLY ALL RIGHT
AND IS THERE ANY HOPE FOR
VILLANOVA THIS YEAR YES YES. GO
A LONG WAY I WOULDN'T I WOULD
RECOMMEND. THANK YOU ALL- WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENTS WHICH IS THAT
CENTER WILSON BIRTHDAY IS ON
WEDNESDAY. SO PLEASE WISH ME A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY WHEN YOU SEE HIM
. BUT THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
BUT SOME REQUIRE THE TEST IS
CLEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT MISTER PRESIDENT YOU
HAVE DONE AN AMAZING JOB TODAY
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND. YEAH. YEAH A
COMMITTEE THAT'S BEEN SENT AWAY
SO. AND IF. TENERGY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS- AND
UTILITIES- COMMITTEE WILL BE
HEARD HERE IN THE SENATE FLOOR
IN TEN MINUTES. EXCELLENT
CINNABAR THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
MISTER PRESIDENT TO INDIA
WHETHER YOU'RE IRISH OR IRISH AT
HEART AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU FOR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION SCHEDULED FOR SAINT
PATRICK'S DAY MARCH SEVENTEENTH
AT NINE AM AGAIN WONDERFUL JOB
MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WE MADE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM.
THE GAL.